dizem que enquanto a civilização maia
foi arrasada pelos conquistadores
espanhóis
eles tiveram que ver os milhares de
livros deles sendo queimados um puro
toda cultura que eles tinham produzido
foi queimada uma por uma e sobraram
quatro livros por acaso
três deles eram conhecidos há muito
tempo mas não foi achado na década de 70
alguma coisa assim mas agora imaginem a
nossa civilização reduzida a quatro
livros mais de dois mil anos de cultura
pensamento a arte história firmados um
por um e sobrassem quatro livros 1
computador e quatro livros escolhidos
por acaso vai poder usar será o campus
mas não facilitar um pouquinho vamos
dizer que a gente pode escolher esses
quatro livros para passar adiante
melhor ainda mas nem que vocês têm que
escolher quatro livros para representar
nossa civilização pode passar hoje em
dia é mais fácil né é um pen drive com
um monte de coisa linda está pensando em
livro ainda pega um pedacinho de papel o
google.com que vira vamos lá vamos dizer
que a gente tem que escolher quatro
livros
o meu amigo impressão pelo menos é que o
nosso primeiro instinto e mail isso a
primeira coisa que me vem na cabeça é
uma tentativa de fazer uma lista mental
dos meus quatro livros favoritos
o que eu mais gosto talvez justamente
por eu ser professor eu me sinto na
obrigação de ser um pouquinho mais
educativa responsabilidade será o legado
de uma civilização
então acho que a gente tem que tentar
ser um pouquinho mais democrático
independente de gosto pessoal vai ter
quem discorda
mas o que eu escolheria ser uma coisa
mais ou menos nessa linha
pelo menos um livro de ciência para
representar registrar o que a gente sabe
um livro de história para registrar o
que a gente passou um conto um romance
para registrar aquilo que a gente
imagina sobre o que a gente não sabe o
que a gente não passou de um livro com
imagens
artes fotos partituras dos patos tudo o
que pudesse colocar e até bom porque não
há chance da nossa civilização ser
substituída por outra que não faz a
menor idéia da nossa língua
pelo menos o último livro ser bonitinho
às vezes enfrenta esse problema de o que
eu quero passar adiante numa escala um
pouco menor
como comentei eu sou professora de
física e às vezes professora tentando
pra falar né aula é tão curta isso se eu
não fujo da matéria mas fica falando
eficiência para mim no fundo deve com
isso eu tô falando para aqueles alunos
um pouquinho sobre a arte ea cultura que
a humanidade produziu até agora eu tô
contando um pouquinho do que teria nas
páginas desses quatro livros como alguns
dos nossos colegas que são hoje em dia
mais apaixonadas pelo que fazem e eu
acabei me tornando um professor por
acaso na época do futebol não faz a
menor idéia do que eu queria fazer da
vida eu não sabia que o meu de 25 anos
também não ia saber e o que eu fiz foi
pegar a lista de cursos da ufrgs eu
comecei a arriscar o que eu não gosto
o problema é que tirando esportes eu
sempre gostei de tudo um pouco a minha
família de escuna era pequeno gostava de
correr pela casa com uma tampa de panela
fazendo assim visando eu queria ser
caminhoneiro era o dia dirigindo mas eu
gostava de desenhar o que já pensa em
fazer jornalismo medicina no fundo fui
me apaixonando mais vozes exatas com o
tempo eu fui riscando eu acabei entrando
engenharias matemática e física mais ou
menos isso
quando cheguei nesse ponto o meu
primeiro passo foi risca matemática e
física porque se eu fizesse um desses
pelo amor de deus é que dá aula a
professora eu acabei escolhendo uma das
engenharias
eu fiquei com o engenheiro mecânico me
inscrevi no vestibular eu passei e
engraçado normalmente as pessoas pensam
em geral mecânica tem a ver com quem
gosta de carro e tal eu até hoje não se
dirigindo em uma bicicleta
mas acontece que eu sempre gostei muito
de explicar coisas talvez mais porque eu
gosto de uma desculpa para falar sobre
as coisas que eu acho interessantes do
que por algum motivo e o pessoal ali de
engenharia da ufrgs tinha um cursinho
pré vestibular voltado para pessoas de
baixa renda e um amigo meu me falando
que eu estava precisando de um professor
de física perguntar eu entrei lá pra
tapar um buraco
e sete anos depois ainda por lá até
coordenador porque eu fui e hoje em douz
o professor e graçado que um dos
problemas que a gente enfrenta em
educação teve justamente com o mesmo
problema de escolher seus quatro livros
como passar a informação adiante não só
qual informação escolher mas o
importante é que ela seja entendida do
melhor jeito possível teve um físico
famosa o chamado bicho definir em uma
entrevista disse alguma coisa do tipo
que toda a explicação depende daquilo
que a pessoa que está ouvindo está
disposta a aceitar como sendo verdade
vai explicar uma coisa que uma pessoa o
que tu vai explicar não depende só do
que está falando
mas também da realidade dessa pessoa o
que para ela faz sentido pra uma verdade
o exemplo que ele demora mais ou menos
como dizer que eu chego pra vocês eu
digo olha a minha tia no hospital
o meu deus por que que eu vou dizer que
ela estava se ano um lugar com neve
daí ela caiu e quebrou o quadril se o
cenário falando num lugar congelado aí é
familiar prates faz parte da realidade
isso é uma verdade pra te eu respondi eu
perguntava isso faz sentido mas isso não
é uma realidade prates não está disposto
a aceitar isso como sendo uma verdade
nós vivemos um momento vai pensar nossa
fala assim estava andando e caiu com é
que eu estava andando no lugar
controlado eo gelo escorregadio
escorregou no gelo se isso faz sentido
que tinha disposto a aceitar como sendo
verdade que o gelo escorrega eu respondi
a tudo isso não faz sentido prático pode
pergunta como assim
jean luís correto porque o gelo
escorrego engraçado que hoje é uma das
coisas que mais escorrega que a gente
conhece um motivo pra isso
isto pegar por exemplo um cubo de gelo
perto o que acontece é que esse gelo
começa a derreter quanto da pisando no
gelo tarrafas não está pressionando joão
bateu bem obrigando ele é ter de se fora
uma fina camada de líquido mais do teu
pé e é isso que escorreria sim com
patins deslizável disposto a aceitar a
inscrição de verdade tudo bem mas isto
não faz sentido prático assim o jogo
aperta o dr
eu não respondi a essa pergunta eu
poderia mais adiante tem uma explicação
legal para isso também
a água é uma das poucas substâncias do
dia a dia que quando com gel é o aumento
de tamanho isso pegar se por exemplo um
copinho com água coloque no congelador
uma forminha de gelo por exemplo quando
o gelo se forma um jogo um pouquinho
maior porque estava o nível da água
antes
é por isso colocar uma latinha de
refrigerante uma champanhe por mais
elegante no congelador e deixar muito
tempo a história porque a água de dentro
expande quando o projeto quando sua
perna desse gelo a desfazendo essa
expansão levemente desfazendo o
congelamento obrigando a derreter-se
está disposto a aceitar esses ganhos de
que eu quero chegar
a idéia é que tudo explicação depende o
lula está disposto a aceitar como sendo
a verdade tem que partir de 1 o que é
esse lugar o que vai fazer uma
explicação fazer sentido depende da
realidade isso é o que ele passou
é interessante pensar na maneira como
educação em si organizadas por isso
pensar por exemplo na indústria voltasse
200 anos na indústria é radicalmente
diferente da indústria hoje em dia
nossas voltasse 20 anos nem do estrela
radicalmente diferente da indústria
gente os hábitos mudaram de
comportamento mudar isso pegasse uma
pessoa dessa indústria nos anos atrás e
colocar seu nome do espírito hoje em dia
ela entra e coloca essa pessoa do lado
de uma loja que vende um liquidificador
ela entra em pânico mas pegasse uma
pessoa de uma sala de aula 200 anos
atrás
colocar os eua numa sala de aula do hoje
em dia ela provavelmente acharão
ambiente familiar tudo bem as cadeiras
são mais confortáveis acordo quadro
mudou um pouco mas a ideia é ao mesmo
tempo um lugar um professor falando
grande número de pessoas ouvindo é
interessante pensar que as tentativas de
mudar isso de novo a educação não foram
poucas
thomas edson falou em 1922 que o vídeo
está destinado a revolucionar o sistema
educacional em alguns anos a subir os
pilares da mente se não totalmente o uso
de livres
todo mundo aqui e já teve com uma
mochila cheia de colégio e da faculdade
sabe que não dança na década de 30
grande promessa de revolução na educação
e no rádio
o rádio era revolucionar as escolas nos
anos 50 e 60 na televisão e ainda assim
na sala de aula hoje continua
praticamente igual à que a gente hoje em
dia a nossa própria promessa de
revolução na educação os tablets e
iphones lousas digitais na sala de aula
no domingo
há quem diga que o motivo disso é
político não existe interesse é difícil
inovar mas talvez em outras coisas por
trás é um estudo realizado pelo doutor
10 mil e que tem um canal decência no
youtube conhecido como meditação
comparou o impacto de diferentes mídias
digitais no aprendizado das pessoas por
exemplo vamos dizer que eu quero
explicar para vocês como é que funciona
ao motor o que será que funciona melhor
que mais eficiente
uma animação mostrando as partes do
motor funcionando o que acontece o
combustível dentro ou uma imagem
descrevendo o que acontece em cada etapa
a nossa animação é melhor eu tô vendo o
que está acontecendo mas acontece que em
estudos controlados se verificou que não
existe nenhuma diferença de
significativa entre os dois sistemas
desde que o conteúdo claro seja mesmo um
novo pode passar mas está tudo pronto e
tudo mais fácil de visualizar talvez
seja justamente esse problema aqui está
todo mundo pronto pra tito não tem que
pensar no que está acontecendo não tem
que se esforçar para visualizar enquanto
na imagem tem que justamente se for só
isso porque ajuda a lembrar que ajuda a
entender fazer associações no fundo
nenhuma mídia é inerentemente melhor que
o fantástico
isso quer dizer que a educação do aluno
não vai ser limitada pelos recursos que
ele oferece 3
no fundo é a capacidade de fazer
associações que vai justamente do
terminal que é melhor que ele vai
aprender com essa facilidade de novas
sanções ao normalmente quando eu digo
para as pessoas que fizerem gerir mas a
cabeça do professor a reação mais comum
é que é um desperdício como sempre
existiu de ganhar dinheiro
os próprios alunos às vezes chegam pra
mim perguntar mas não trabalha só dá
aula
hoje em dia eu faço parte de um
o projeto que faz vídeos na internet e
eu faço os vídeos de física e atualmente
está com mais de um milhão de
visualizações por cima e crescendo ea
série de comentários de lula agradecendo
dizendo me salva obrigado é sensacional
eu queria que as pessoas que ficam em
dúvida sobre essa minha escolha
entendessem que quando eu estou falando
com os alunos um pouquinho sobre isso
sobre falando
a comunidade fez até agora eu me sinto
escrevendo algumas das páginas dessas
quatro livros
eu estou contando com ele uma pequena
visão que a gente tem até hoje em dia
às vezes gosto de pensar como seria
interessante se a gente pudesse fazer o
contrário a gente pudesse reunir esses
partidos e ao invés de deixar eles para
a geração seguinte a gente pudesse levar
ele pro passado e contar para aquelas
pessoas que ainda não viram isso que
tudo fantástico comunidade fazer todos
os dois mil anos de arte concluir
ciência e pensamento tão por não ser eu
achei sensacional mas danças eu entro na
sala de aula eu me dou conta que os
alunos que estão ali não são muito
diferentes daquelas pessoas do passado
no sentido de que eles ainda não têm um
pouquinho menos que eles sabem sobre
todos esses dois mil anos de arte e
cultura ciência e pensamento
e para esses alunos eu posso que são
certa forma mas na civilização seguinte
uma geração seguinte eu posso justamente
contar tudo que eu sei sobre o que teria
nas páginas de seus quatro livros
obrigado